[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
taylor swift made her latest saturday
night live appearance one for the books
in one night the singer collabed with
pete davidson delivered an epic
10-minute performance and reunited with
her bff selena gomez like how lucky am i
first let's focus on the t-swift
collaboration we didn't see coming
[Music]
[Applause]
the songstress teamed up with pete for a
musical sketch roasting new snl writers
titled three sad virgins
he looks like a big bird lost all his
feathers now the song didn't start out
as a diss track i had this idea where
maybe we could do like a music video
about how we're all like best friends
and how we're like boys they we would be
in it with you yeah you guys would be
the boys the names are martin ben and
john and they work at the showroom they
just don't have any swag they're tall
and weird and sad yeah that dream for
the guys quickly turned into a nightmare
especially when taylor joined in none of
[Music]
tay them double duty also appearing as
the show's musical guest delivering an
epic 10-minute performance of the new
version of her song all too well
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
and almost her on backstage her bestie
selena taylor shared their happy reunion
on tick tock
oh no
my bestie
is a bad [ __ ]
it's so good let's just see it one more
time oh no
my bestie
is a bad [ __ ]
it's been a big weekend for the grammy
winner with the release of her short
film for all too well which she directed
[Music]
plus tay also dropped the re-recording
of her album red which now features get
this
30 songs it's maximalism
it's just a lot of a lot and when e.t
spoke with taylor last week she couldn't
help but gush over her fans who she says
made this whole thing a reality this was
something that started out as a really
hard thing i went through
the fans are the people who turned it
into something very empowering where
when they they were just saying to me
over and over again we want to listen to
your versions if you redo it that's what
we'll listen to so if they hadn't if
they hadn't done that i don't think i'd
be having this amazing
exciting experience of being here and
you're here and there's a short film of
one of my favorite songs i've ever
written and so that's all the fans doing
and so this is really i just wanted to
think about what could i do over the
course of one week that would make them
as happy
or try to make them as happy as they've
made me